Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week because
Comic Con is coming up this video is going
to be a preview of all things Game of Thrones
going on there.
Including what merch you can blow all your
savings on, when all the panels are and the
separate stuff George RR Martin is doing.
Don't worry if you can't go I will be recording
the Panel in Hall H. And I'm doing a special
giveaway in addition to the regular book giveaway
that I'll explain at the end of this video.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything, it's
going to be crazy, but a lot of fun
Starting with the big stuff first Comic Con
starts this wednesday July 23rd and ends on
Sunday the 27th.
The biggest stuff always happens on Friday
and Saturday.
The big Hall H panel is Friday the 25th at
1:40PM Pacific Time.
I'll be recording a bunch of panels.
But because of all your votes in the poll
I've got going Game of Thrones will be the
first panel I post on my channel Friday night.
There's a link for that in the description,
so you can keep voting throughout the weekend.
Internet is really crappy at Comic Con but
I've done a bunch of upgrades to my Comic
Con Emergency Preparedeness Kit so let's say
I'll post that by 8PM that night.
If I have to I'll break it into two separate
videos or just cut out all the parts with
people screaming to make it shorter.
Season 5 is in the middle of filming right
now, so HBO is only flying in a few cast members,
including Gwendoling Christie who also just
started work on Star Wars Episode 7, Nikolaj
Coster-Waldeau, Natalie Dormer, Kit Harington,
all the women would riot if they didn't bring
him, Rose Leslie, Jon and Ygritte final reunion.
Rory McCann and Maisie Williams, Team Fuck
the King, Sophie Turner and Pedro Pascal,
who I think will end up being the fan favorite.
He's just an awesome guy in real life.
Dan and Dave will be there too and George
RR Martin of course, who also does a bunch
of stuff on his own there too.
Craig Ferguson is moderating, so brace thyself,
Jokes are coming.
He's actually really good, so I'm happy they
asked him to do it.
I know Peter Dinklage and Lena Headey aren't
there along with a bunch more of the main
cast, but they're busy filming other movies
right now.
What are they going to do on the panel?
The Game of Thrones panel is a little different
from most of the big Hall H movie and tv panels.
They usually do not show off new footage or
trailers.
They do talk a lot about the next season but
mostly it's a Q&A where the cast tells stories
about the awesome stuff they do on set and
the way they percieve their characters.
The big questions we'll probably see them
get asked are Jon and Ygritte stuff, Arya
and the Hound stuff and the Dan and Dave and
Martin questions will be mostly about the
show passing the books.
They've already answered that question, Martin
gave them a blueprint for where all the characters
need to end up at the end.
So worst case scenario, we get to season 8
of the show before Winds of Winter is published.
They'll still know what to do.
It will just be like a Walking Dead situation
where the show becomes very different from
the books, except for the really really important
stuff.
Like I said, I will at least post the best
parts of the panel this Friday Night.
Last Year Jason Momoa crashed it, so with
any luck the new Mountain Hafthor Bjornson
will crash and he and Pedro Pascal can do
a rematch.
In fact, let me know if you agree that it
would be better for them to just rent out
a fighting ring and just have them re-enact
the fight.
And that would be way more fun than a regular
Hall H panel.
Next on the Agenda, what about all the other
Game of Thrones stuff that's going on?
There's all the George RR Martin events separate
from the tv show and then there's all the
new merch to blow your savings on.
This probably won't blow your mind but Martin
has a new comic book he's doing a panel for
that has nothing to do with A Song of Ice
and Fire.
It's called In the House of The Worm and it
feels like a very John Cartery of Mars type
story where it's on another planet, but it's
a fantasy story.
He's usually really nice about answering Winds
of Winter questions, I won't be recording
this panel, but if he says anything new about
the books I'll add it to my next bonus video.
Here's the info on the new swag they'll be
selling, a lot of this stuff you can find
online later in case you're not going to be
there.
HBO is going to have a big pop up shop in
the gaslamp district selling a bunch of stuff.
That's away from the convention center so
you don't need a badge to get in.
That will be open Thursday through Sunday.
Funko Pop will be on the convention floor
selling the regular figures and a new line
called mystery mini's that are black and white
versions of the dead characters.
So you can buy like a black and white Ned
Stark mini.
There's a new fuzzy version of Ghost and a
glowing White Walker Head.
Dark Horse Comics will be selling a Flayed
Man Bolton Map Marker, A Lannister Shield
and mini's of the dragons.
Threezero, the company that makes those really
awesome Dead Space statues will be selling
their first Game of Thrones Tyrion figure.
You'll be able to buy it online eventually
too.
And then David Peterson, the person who creates
all the Languages for the show like Dothraki
and Vaylrian has a new book he'll be there
promoting called Living Language Dothraki:
A Conversational Language Course.
He has his own booth that they'll be running
games at where you can win swag prizes all
weekend.
The book will be on sale October 7th.
That's all the Official HBO and Big Publisher
stuff happening, but artists alley is always
a good place to hit up if you have a bad ass
idea for a sketch of Tyrion Riding Drogon
you want to commission.
I actually have a few friends that are artists,
so I might do giveaways like that when Season
5 gets here next year.
Speaking of which, here's the details on my
Comic Con giveaway.
I'm Giving away a Ghost and a Drogon Funko
Pop figure to two different people.
Each person gets one of them.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
The week after comic con I'll pick two random
peoples from the comments.
So the giveaway will be open longer than normal.
This is all in addition to the regular book
giveaway, I'm still doing that this week too.
Which reminds me, congrats to Michal Plevka
you are this week's book winner.
I'll be messaging you on your channel, so
check your inbox.
So big reminders, Friday Night this week I'll
be posting that Game of Thrones Panel, I'll
also be tweeting the shit out of it while
it's happening so if you want you can follow
me on social.
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram links all at
the bottom of the description.
Right now click here to learn about the Golden
Company and click here to learn all about
the Blackfyre Rebellion.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!